oh my God
sorry if I had known that the commercial
would get this kind of response I would
have been much more optimistic about my
career I don't remember the similar
enthusiasm at the time my director
almost fired me and now I can see why
what do you remember from filming that
commercial other than you just gave a
tidbit you were almost fired yes I do
remember that I remember a couple of
things one they asked me I was I was 16
or just maybe turned 17 and I remember
the guy with the car guy you know
because it was a car in the commercial
and I had to drive and they're always
worried about actors driving
I remember he asked me to this day
there's him and some teamsters and they
were standing around he goes do you know
how to drive kid it was in New York and
I was like yeah yeah I know how to drive
you were sure and I was like guys I've
driven like 500 or A Thousand Miles
lifetime have you I guess we're all set
and I also remember being like I don't
know why this director uh keeps making
me do it over and over again and now
looking at the performance I have about
better idea ah director to director and
I love your directing so much Ben
Affleck I saw error this is the fifth
film you've directed
um
did you shoot on film or digital I was
trying to find the answer we shot Super
8 and 16 millimeter film and we also
shot uh these old video cameras like the
three tube video cameras where when you
would move you know the little lights
would streak sort of like the highlights
you know and because I felt like
part of convincing people that you're in
a different period of time is like we
connect those things to the way we
experience life then and that was the
media that we were looking at stuff on
so I did both and then I took the
digital and and and and and Bob
Richardson and I did a lot to the put a
lot of glass in front of it and did a
lot of things including making Matt look
a little more Squat and wide which she
was happy about and um to to sort of
make it look different and to make it
feel more 80s because people if they
look back on it fondly they kind of
associate that with your movie and that
opening Montage
yeah the like the references of Our
Lives guys when you watch this first of
all if you didn't live through it you
will understand like what the gadgetry
was like what the technology is like
with the food and the soda cans and the
walkmans and you know I heard you do I
was like watching you in the movies at
that time okay that's what was going on
[Applause]
you're you're right but the the choices
you made as a filmmaker like I'll tackle
another one which was we've I've heard
you out there saying you didn't want to
have Michael Jordan or an actor play him
so smart everyone's gonna look at that
and just be like that's not Jordan so
those choices are so brilliant I don't
believe it would be possible to get an
audience to believe that anyone other
than Michael Jordan is Michael Jordan
and so to see his face and try to sell
there he is
it would not only lose the audience but
then they wouldn't believe they'd be
like oh this is all false this is all
alive and so much of the work that
you're trying to do is create realism
it's really his mom's story it's not his
story so in fact talking to him he was
quite he was like this my mom did this
my mom took me to Oregon he was I wanted
to play Nintendo I was like what you
mean so you know that that thing about
what a given is is Sadie would have you
know sold his the rights for a red
Mercedes
um so it's not that he was driving that
aspect of it he's brilliant he's the
greatest you know competitive athlete
ever
um but his without his mom
um I don't think things would have
worked as they did which is why part of
the movie really is a kind of a love
letter to Mom's and an homage to that
women who who do a lot of that work
often and and without reward or approval
or approbation or tension
um and I hope this was a kind of a
gesture to say you know you know this
guy would not have been this guy and I
think many many men and women would not
be who they were without the these sort
of unfailing support of of in
particularly in this you know their moms
but then there's a montage I don't want
to give anything away but you do tap
into what his future will hold and you
don't shy away from just showing the
victories you showed the difficult
things he goes through the painful
why did you choose to include that
well because that's part of it and if
you're the greatest in the world you're
like by definition alone and I didn't
expect people to go oh we're going to
feel sorry for Michael Jordan because
you know he's that doesn't work and I
believe like when you look at Michael
and his career and the degree to which
he just seems to be consumed with a need
to be great and to win and be the best
I think that's a lot to carry around
probably all there do we have a clip
let's take a quick look you got a name
for it
for what
Michael Jordan line
you want to make him this offer you're
talking about damn well better have a
Michael Jordan line
yeah uh well that was a thought that um
Pete actually
thinks we should call it
Air Jordan
ah
I don't know it's so brilliant okay
sorry pivot how do you direct a scene
like Argo if that's the edge of your
seat scene I've seen it 50 times and
you're just like oh my God I love that
haircut another plane the plane the
plane
no what I found is that you get it's
hard because you go like well geez
everybody uh knows what's gonna happen
right so that you think well this makes
my job difficult but actually the truth
is you get a lot of Tailwind because
people already know what happened and
they kind of enjoy being in on it like
it's not about the outcome the audiences
don't I don't think watch movies to see
the plot resolve okay most of you know
what the resolution is going to be if
you think about it it's really that if
you connect to the characters
emotionally and you believe in them and
you identify with them you want to see
them Reach a resolution because it makes
you feel better and that is why you are
Ben Affleck
[Music]